when well when did you have sex with the
first uh i had uh the first time
with a human being
how many years were you the mailman i
was a mailman i
i lasted about five months five months
and were you any were you any good at it
or not i moved to chicago soon after i
was a mail carrier and
probably a year later i found
undelivered mail under my seat that's
how bad
well that's awful yeah i know
[Applause]
it was probable it was probably somebody
with a check that they needed to get
they foreclosed on the house but as a
mailman you i'm sure did the right thing
i did
i did do the right thing what would you
say that would have been
i would have i would have deposited into
an active mail receptacle to make sure
they got their delayed mail or the
garbage
oh no that's
well no
you you look sensational have you been
working on you i mean your upper chest
just right there that's that i mean it's
really it's buff thank you it's like
it's oh
yeah that's the sound i make when i do
it really yeah dude you see me in the
flies i go
really
do you do the upside down ones what are
they called i do the upside they're
called the upside down
i go to the gym and i just i make a lot
of noise because i want people to see me
lifting weights
do you ever see those guys that try to
lift like a thousand pounds yes why do
they do that i don't know you're going
to hurt yourself doing that things are
popping out yeah
that's what i'm there for that's the
only reason i go to the gym things
popping out
there with my binoculars
even although we're indoors and it's
quite a small room i still carry
binoculars so people know i'm a pair of
it's fun yeah especially when they're
wearing spandex you just see you go
what's your best beauty tip
pluck
no questions luck don't ask i won't
you know i'm i'm now not on the uh the
office anymore by the way how is that
going you don't know yet how it's going
do you i don't well i know james spader
is coming in right and i think that's a
great move i think he's going to be
fantastic um so and i've been in touch
with cast members and they're excited
about but you're still in the rhythm of
you might go back at the end of your
break but you haven't gone back yeah you
you sort of feel like wow everybody else
is going back to school and i've
graduated and it feels it's a little bit
odd because i know everybody you know
i'm going to miss my friends that's
that's the main thing but weren't you
tired of carrying that dog yeah
you know what now that you say that
screw that show
what did that show ever do for me that's
right
what was going on in your head i wanted
to look like magnum p.i
i actually grew a mustache in high
school because i played lacrosse and i
thought it would make me look more
threatening
and it didn't really it just made me
look like a porn star
i don't know if other men have this same
experience
but in in in a high place in that kind
of fear my testicles fold into my body
they really do like
standing on a ledge it's like oh
and
um this is called the joyless laughing
guy joyless laughing guy yeah i'll try
to do it i can do it sitting down okay
[Laughter]
you were really that hairy to be oh i'm
extremely hair i'm a hairy guy yes yeah
yeah so you're and you're hairy backhand
front i have i i have more hair than
skin
you're like a missing link i am i am on
the on that evolutionary chart i'm this
guy
doctor i'd like to talk to you about
my
elongated
there's a doctor in this town that would
do it guarantee it yeah
they would pause for a second say very
well i've done several of these yeah
yeah
probably not the first doctor you go to
but some at some point some doctor's
gonna go okay yeah
okay they're pretty expensive
i think we can get that flush from your
heel
what i mean is we're gonna drill a hole
in your heels
and we'll extract a cork of flesh
and then we will insert oh man
so anyway back to back to the kids so
you and the kids and your wife you're
doing things this summer yeah you're
spending a lot a lot of time like more
time than i've spent in a long time is
it good is it satisfying it's so boring
it's
it's i you know it's nice to relish that
time with your children but your kids
are infinitely less cute when you spend
more time with them
there's a bug called the greeny i don't
know if they're out here necessarily but
on the shore in massachusetts there are
a lot of them and they're kind of like
mosquitoes
but they're kind of like really bastard
mosquitoes they're bastards they're
bastard they're bastard bugs whereas a
mosquito will kind of say
okay i'm i'm i'm biting you i'm biting
you now and you can oh no i'm okay sorry
about that was i thinking a greeny
a greeny will like walk up to your skin
or fly up and just go
ah
and it's they are you really they're
idiots too because you just go boom and
they're dead they don't fly away they
look at you like ah okay kill me but
they they will gnaw through your leg
they'll actually bite you through those
chairs really yes they will get
underneath and bite you up through the
chair
i have scars on my legs from greeny
they're like they are bugs they give you
the finger while they are biting wow
that's a tough that's it
[Music]
that chart of
ape to man yeah i'm about four down from
man
i'm not hunched over
when you're the guy with stone tools
yeah stone tools yeah i'm this
um
when you can see your body hair in your
own shadow yeah
this is the last season and and yeah
right yeah and
yeah but i understand your character
you're not going back i'm not going back
now
why not i don't like those people
you know
boy or girl girl yeah and what is that
like to have a nine year old she um i
was explaining to her the other day
about what television used to be
um and i said the televisions had knobs
and she could not she really didn't
understand the concept of a knob she
didn't know
so you had to go to the television and
click it right and there were probably
four viable channels that's right to to
go to what about the kids channel
no no there were no kids
channels that's right it's all about
them now you know
it's all about me what about the kids
what about disney channel
did that disney channel no you watched
you watch cartoons on saturday morning
and if you missed them too bad you were
out of luck
and then then you would have to watch
really what mom and dad wanted to watch
right pretty much or you go to bed yeah
and mom and dad are
exactly the way it was
[Applause]
or you know what
or mom and a mom and dad have a nice
cocktail that's the way it used to be
i thought it would be funny to just
stand in front of people and yell things
through the german accent i think one of
them was let's all pile into the minivan
and get some frozen yogurt
it was a pleasure babysitting kevin
you're not getting older you are getting
better
i support whatever people want to do i
don't you know i don't well except nazis
i don't know i mean in terms of what
you're eating oh i see i said i support
everybody i'm like well i don't support
nazis steve come on you know what though
if a nazi wanted to be a vegan fine
you're a more tolerant than that
i'd be like no you finished your
sausages hitler
i don't know
it might work out
over the years i've learned there are
certain things to get your wife for her
birthday and certain things that you do
not get well this is useful for example
for example jewelry is always good um a
night out is always good you know some
sort of clothing that she liked that's
always good i bought her a camera this
year we have little kids that's nice
yeah absolutely do not
give her an inflatable exercise ball
um do not give her a handwritten coupon
for a back rub
any sort of facial cream is just
not a good idea
my brother once gave my mom a mop for
her birthday
and that
that went over here work a little harder
with the mop and then when you're done
quilting get the kitchen floor
what on screen the co-star were you most
nervous to kiss the rock
i kissed him and got smart and how was
that pretty great yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
i've moved into sexual ambiguity now
you